hello
how you guys doing
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel i want to
introduce you to a guy called dan he is
absolutely smashing it in the property
investment space with rent to rent he's
buying a whole bunch of houses i think
you're going to be really really
inspired and educated through this video
because he's making a clean profit of 12
000 pounds per month with just a few
small handful of rent to rent properties
he doesn't even own and in this video
he's going to be sharing exactly how
he's done it and how you can do the same
thing too dan welcome to winners on a
wednesday thank you very much it's a
pleasure to be here so you joined the
academy a couple years ago that's why
you're like the two-year academy member
yeah it was i think the launch pad was
in july
2019 it was yeah so just give us dan a
little bit of a back story because we're
going to get on to what you've achieved
how you've built up this little
portfolio which is making a really good
profit but what was it that drew you to
myself to property in general and how
did this all get started yeah sure so
well i worked for the post office for 21
years
and they made me they made me redundant
and i made the decision to leave the job
and at the time i was fighting
professionally and i had a brick built
gym in my garden i was teaching personal
training i was teaching thai boxing on a
just on the side really as well as my
post office wages i was learning from
there as well
and then when i made me redundant i went
into full-time thai boxing coaching and
i realized it's such a physical job what
i do
i can handle it now you know i can
handle it then for the next 10 years i'm
absolutely fine but
looking looking into the future it's um
it's a physical job i need i needed to
earn some money some money from another
stream of income i needed to get into
something i've always had a passion for
property so um
yeah after talking to holly about what
we wanted to do and stuff we decided
property was a good vehicle you know so
i just engulfed myself into books
property videos youtube videos and
that's where i come across you yeah you
know i mean i come across you you say
are you the postman that you don't want
to piss off the the postman that's also
a fighter as well you know almost i'm as
soft as [ __ ] mate
yeah now other than i was a postman for
six years and then i went into the into
the cash handling side of stuff so i was
the i was the man with a helmet and the
smoke and die box you know going making
other people rich basically but it was a
good job i was happy i was comfortable i
didn't dislike my job it was good money
but then the redundancies come and i
decided to take the plunge it was it
wasn't an easy decision so you went from
being a postman to training people
martial arts fitness yeah and then you
thought this is great i'm making a
living but i'm not gonna be able to do
it forever physically so i need to get
into something else yeah exactly that
you came down to the crash course in
2019
i think it
holly left to remind me it was about
february 19 it was beginning of the year
done the crash course what was that what
was the crash course like it was
brilliant yeah it was it was brilliant
it took me a while to get my head around
it with everyone getting up and you know
having a little dance on stage and that
me and holly relief was all this about
but it was great you know it's long days
but i learned so much and i walked away
feeling fired up like this is definitely
what i want to do this is where i want
to go what was it that made you take the
plunge to going from the property
investors crash course which is a free
training program which just opens
people's eyes teaches them all the
foundations what made you then go right
i'm going all in and joining the academy
i'm one of them people when i i'm just
if i set my mind to say if i make a
decision i'll go for it you know um
and i just spoke to a lot of people at
the crash calls who are doing it and
living and breathing it and i could see
people being successful and i just
thought you know what i'll go on to the
next course and i think there's a dfe
that i've done next i paid for the dfe
holly and i had done the dfv spent i
think
two or three grand i think it was at the
champions league i can't remember where
it was yeah but that's it i just i don't
know i just felt like after the crash
calls this this is definitely i knew i
was interested in property but then
after that crash call you kind of sealed
it i thought yeah you know what i didn't
realise i had all these options i didn't
realize i could refinance i didn't
realize i could i didn't realize i could
get access to some of the funds you know
i mean i thought i was kind of at the
game i wasn't earning much as a personal
trainer i thought i thought it was all
about you needed a lot of money you know
what i mean but it weren't so i was
excited so what happened next
well we've done the dfe um still finding
extravagant still fine extravaganza um
holly was with me we both both learnt
lows we went home that night and we're
doing scripts we're driving home on a
motorway we've been doing scripts we
pretending we're talking to landlords
and stuff like that and um yeah i
started to go around a few agencies in
my local town oh i joined i joined the
academy at the dfe yeah sorry that's
what i don't know yeah that's what we've
done we joined the academy at the dfe
and uh yeah was excited and um yeah i
started going around my local agents in
watford that's where i live and um
didn't really get anywhere at first you
know i mean um but then when i joined
the academy and then i went to the rent
revolution in july just after the launch
pad july 2019 july 2019 yeah and that's
when i'll learn
a little bit more about rent-a-rants
what is your interest yeah basically
which is what i'm doing um i'm basically
paying the landlords they rent every
single month we agree on a three year
turn with like maybe a 12 12 month break
laws i have done in all my contracts so
we um we paid them their rent every
month every single month i pay all the
bills i've got a great maintenance team
cleaning team in the area i've got a lot
of things systemized now and i basically
run it on short-term let's i do use um
otas like airbnb booking.com travago
vrbo and whatnot um and i run it like a
hotel so guests come in they check
themselves in with a key safe um you
know they do what they do they have a
good time and then they check out and
the cleaners go in they make it look all
nice again and yeah we run it like a
hotel so basically you profit you give a
guaranteed rent a general rent but then
you put people in and you profit from
the difference now normally when people
do that and this is what i want to do on
wins on a wednesday normally people make
500 to a thousand pounds per month per
property that's what we teach right
right
generally speaking people are making
five hundred two thousand pounds and
we'll say you only need three or four of
those and you can replace your income
you got two or three of those
and the the profits from them was
ridiculous
like crazy you know what i'll be honest
with you though it
i didn't set out to get a big five
bedroom 1.6 million pound townhouse for
my first deal
yeah i didn't i was out there looking
for a two bedroom bath and flat you know
and um i was going around with iron i
was getting knocked backs for months you
know
i was getting told that you're wasting
your time you get people like you in
every day you know you're wasting your
time now landlords ain't up for it the
leaseholds don't allow it you know it
can deflate you
but i kept going and kept going and kept
going and then i just i built a
relationship with one particular agent
and i got a viewing and i said to holly
i've got a few i've got a few in this
[ __ ] so i'm not going to take it but i'm
going to go anyway because i can build a
relationship with this agent and um
that's what i've done and me and this
agent we connected and she could see my
work ethic she could see that i was
genuine and
and there was one day i'll never forget
it it was it was chucking it down with
rain it was on a tuesday so i allowed
tuesdays i keep tuesday's free now so i
could do my property investing it was a
tuesday and it was chucking it down with
rain and uh
i was i was like man i can't be asked to
go out i've got no meetings i've got no
viewings but then i had a proper word
with myself and i went when it went to
wins i went to this age and i said to
that lady look i know you are going to
call me if anything comes up but you
know if you've got anything she goes you
know i've got this house and long story
short i went and viewed it and i knew
straight away because of the location i
knew straight away it was going to work
you can see the castle you can see the
thames it's
it's just undergone a full refurb
i it couldn't not work yeah but there's
this element of doubting me because i
ain't done it before do you know what i
mean so
yeah that was my first deal and the
roller coaster we went with that was
unbelievable securing it negotiating it
was up for 4100 a month it reduced down
to four and i got it for 3 350. so i got
really happy with what i got here for um
yeah
and yeah and and then we had issues with
with um the council they told me i
needed an hmo license
and i'm like no i'm not running it as an
hmo and then the landlord didn't want to
know anymore she was doing an hmo and
i'm not running it as a nature no i'm
sorry i'm not interested so then i had
to contact the council and get them to
put it in writing i don't need it and
then the landlord was back in and then
they said we needed planning and i said
we don't and they sent their guys around
to do an inspection and you know they
said everything was all right fire
safety and all that and then we got it
and then it was the issues with a
guarantor they wanted to guarantor and i
reached out to another academy why do
they want to guarantor well because i'm
a new business you know what i mean i i
couldn't personally guarantee it's a one
point six the rent was oh it said i
needed i needed to be earning about 150
grand
and that's why again we teach
we teach find a studio or find it but
you went and did it like 10 times bigger
but then i'm like what do i do i reached
out i found another academy member yeah
who who had already got a couple of
units and i believe that he could help
me with the finances and i said right we
need a we can't personally guarantee we
need a guarantor can you get one yeah
yeah yeah and in the end he couldn't get
a guarantor i found a guarantor a friend
of mine he become our guarantor
you know but then he wouldn't sign the
paperwork he said i don't want him let's
see in my bank statements i don't want
to know my finances he said i can't do
it dan and then they wanted six months
rent up front so we had to get a third
joint venture partner with the finances
so we didn't want to lose the deal yeah
and then they just even after we paid
six months rent up front they still
wanted the guarantor but they didn't
want the proof of his earnings and his
bank statements so he was he was a
guarantor so you had a lot of doors but
here's the thing though dan a lot of
people would have said oh it's a sign
it's not meant to be oh the the the hmo
license the planning of this but you
understood the rules you're like it's
not a hmo i don't need planning council
you're wrong yeah this is the fact this
is because of your education you're able
to say that yeah i wouldn't have known
otherwise i wouldn't know enough always
and i was confident as well anthony
helped me as well i phoned him up and he
confirmed i was definitely right and
yeah that got all that cleared up so you
went through so many hurdles so many
hurdles to secure that deal it's
unbelievable and then when we got it me
and holly had it we were celebrating you
know as our first deal well excited and
then yeah then we got it and
holly dunno what she's amazing at and
she furnished it she's like the creative
side of the business yeah i mean yeah
she takes care of her marketing the
creative side she's built a great
instagram page and um
what she can do with interior designing
is amazing it's why we're so successful
at the end of the day well it's great to
have someone behind i mean i know she
was the person that told you to join the
academy in the first place you know she
was like do it but if their face she was
like dang oh that's a lot of money babe
yeah just do it down you'll smash it
good cut the drinks as well yeah let's
do it no regrets no regrets so that
first house right you don't own it
you're renting it yeah you're paying
three thousand three thousand three
hundred and fifty for the three thousand
three to fifty it's a big flat you can
see windsor castle flat mate it's a
house oh it's a house sorry it's a big
house you can see windsor castle prime
spot amazing
3350 you guaranteed to pay the landlord
are you not stressed that you're not
going to be able to get people in it and
you're going to have to pay the landlord
the money anyway
initially it was a worry you know i mean
but then now because even through
lockdown we've we've never we've never
lost money
even through lockdown we've been
fortunate our first guest is our first
guest come from that agent who got me
here five months seven grand a month for
five months our first guest so she
stayed there for five months yeah you're
paying three thousand three hundred
she's paying you seven grand yeah and
you're making all that profit right we
couldn't couldn't get off to a dream
start couldn't go off to a better start
it was worth the hassle hundred percent
what how's that first deal doing now
it's it's smashing it we've just we've
just said we've just had a couple from
america they lived over there for nine
months paying seven grand a month for
nine months
man you know we had our cleaners going
every two weeks they left it spotless
how much profit is that then like three
grand on that one yeah but what we've
done is we provided a couple of cleans
as well it's about 2006 right pure
profit taking away the maintenance and
that's but from one deal totally and
that's when they're staying there for
months on end
crazy so what did you think of that when
that happened what did you think when
you got that guess that one started
coming in
it was exciting i was excited it was a
really it was a relief yeah i mean
because it's a it's a new venture it's
my first unit yeah
here's a question for you dan if you
hadn't seen
all the other people winning in rent to
rent if you hadn't seen all the other
academy members that were like i'm doing
it i'm doing i'm doing it
would you have had the
assurance to keep going when they're
staged of slamming the door in your face
probably not probably i mean i've got
that personality i don't just i don't
just
quit
you know i mean i'll keep going i'll
keep going i'll keep going it's the same
as what i was saying earlier about
about my academic level you know i mean
i struggled to learn but i i knew i was
going to get to where i wanted to get to
but it's just going to take me a bit
longer because it takes me longer to get
my head around things and understand
things you know what i mean so like you
know i said to the question i don't know
i probably wouldn't have given up but
like it was all against us there was
times i was thinking it's just not going
to happen you know
we had issues and each and every night i
just remember something else when
inspectors did come round we're on the
full floor it's over four floors on the
ensuite there's a boiler and there's a
uh a water tank and he says all that
wool you've got to make it um fireproof
it's going to be fireproof the landlady
she agreed to she paid 1500 pounds to
have it all
fireproofed you know i mean because she
really she met me and my business
partner she interviewed us and she asked
us loads of questions and she loved us
she was like here's some interesting
note that landlady if she's watching
this video she might think oh i could
just do it like that but it takes so
much knowledge and skill to be able to
run it you've got it on all these
different online agents yeah you've got
all the systems and procedures to be
able to take the bookings you've you
you've learned and it's a business yeah
it'd be like someone going oh you're
running a restaurant i'm making all that
money well i'll just run a restaurant
well you kind of can't you kind of need
to know what you're doing i don't know
what you said she was running out by the
room before to some students and they
trashed it right so her main concern was
that the house is going to get wrecked
it's just she i think it's 130 grand
she'd spent on having it all done up and
her main concern was because it's eaten
you know cup of cocoa and bed at 10 and
everyone's you know like this
she was worried there's going to be
disturbance she was worried it was going
to be like her house is going to get
trashed but then when she met us and we
just we explained exactly how we're
going to run it and how our cleaners are
going to be in there through two or
three days a week and if there's any
damage you know i guess pay a deposit
they will pay for it and we give it back
to her in the same condition she was
relieved and she let us and she just
built in another property right now
in the same area in the back garden two
bedroom two bathrooms you run me
upstairs then you can take that when
it's done wow i mean so
what was the rent to rent revolution
like well that's what got me there in
the end you know after the dfe i was
fired up i was going around i was making
progress but then after the rental rent
revolution you just you just learned it
a little bit more in depth and it gave
me that little bit more confidence to
just go out there and yeah and that's
that's when i secured my first deal i
loved it i enjoyed it it really did what
was the second property that you got
the second one
was a fight another five bedroom is a
detached house with a big drive for free
you can fit six of them little mini cars
in it if you really wanted to but
again it's a prime location it's a five
minute stroll into the center of windsor
of windsor and it's um
it's got an amazing kitchen dining area
you walk in and you've got a living room
which we just made into a master ensuite
bedroom you know it's hollywood she's
done with that room is unbelievable it's
amazing and then you go into the kitchen
and you've got a big kitchen diner it's
got a massive extension with bluetooth
speakers in it all kitchenaid kitchen
appliances
and um yeah that one was three and a
half grand a month rent and the agent
actually put me directly in touch with
the landlord because he was like i want
to talk to him i want to talk to this
guy you know if i'm going to rent my
house room i want to understand his
business model yeah and i'm not not only
that you know i'll put an offering for
290 guys i'm not i want to talk to him
about the price and after a couple of
negotiations and cut the phone calls
with him we agreed on 3000 a month rent
for the whole three years so we've got a
really good
really good price on the rent and um and
what what holly done with this is with
the interior design it was like she'd
learned a lot from eaton doing eaton
there's a few things in eating she
wasn't happy with so when we went into
this house amazing and then we then she
launched the instagram page and we've
had celebrities footballers influencers
in there and everything so
it's more of a success than the first
one i'll be honest with you what we're
actually charging a little bit more how
can it be more successful than the first
one it's just i think it's what's
holly's done
with the designing how much is that how
much is that one making we so we have
people contacting us regularly they want
to do video shoots and filming and
everything in there because it's it's
it's how much uh over those have you got
three rental rents that are i know
you've got keys coming yeah yeah yeah
yeah right now you've got three that are
actually making money yeah you've got
more in the in the bag yeah you've got
more about to go live but three of them
running yeah those out between the three
of them
how much of that of cash flow they
brought in over the last couple of
months over the last couple right well
this is the thing i was trying i was
talking to you know about this on the
way up here july and august
net profit between the three or 12 grand
nice each per month so 24 grand
24 grand for two months next 12 grand i
know i can't get med rounds on three
properties it's just ridiculous it's
about nine the flats are about 95
percent 90 to 95 percent i was looking
on toki toki is the booking platform
here you need to say calendars and that
that tells you if you're going to the
dashboard sort of like your occupancy
rates and how much money you'll be so
you didn't miss it it definitely isn't
1200
100 100 and also you've got you're about
to pick up the keys to another rental
rent which is
even bigger
that's you know
that's again that's
putting ourselves out of our comfort
zone because it's a different area it's
a different strategy we're reaching out
to a different sort of um audience or
different kind of different kind of
guests people are going to be staying
for one month to 12 months and celeste
generally either people with very well
often or celebrities footballers we have
a football review in it next week um
yeah that's that's the converted barn
that's right that's unbelievable i'll be
staying there
i'll post it when it's done so what do
you think what would you say to those
people that told you 18 months ago rent
to rent doesn't work
well the proof is in the pudding you
know i mean i i just i don't know there
were certain people close to me that
were a bit skeptical not
out you know available area is good and
what areas where you learn all that do
you know what i mean so i was confident
with the areas i chose it was going to
work yeah it's not look it's not guess
work yeah you do it you go through it's
all formulas but now at the beginning i
was unsure as well when you listen to
people who are quite negative it worries
y'all yeah now i've been doing it for a
while and the results are there i've
seen the results and
at the moment it's unbelievable this
you know it's been it's been weird for
the last year it's been we've got
through it we've made money yeah we
haven't even lost money like through the
lockdown we've managed to like the the
landlady eaten blessed she actually gave
us like a rent reduction for three
months the foot through the first
lockdown she dropped it down to 1500 a
month and we still made money through
that that period and we paid her extra
to say thank you we give her an extra
500 and said thank you for that you know
but we've you know we've actually made
money yeah that was yeah it was a bit
hairy you know but we got through it and
built a business because when lockdown
first happened you weren't even allowed
to stay at hotels so it was crazy we
were lucky because that that family that
was in there for five months the first
guests
yeah they were in there because they was
wait ready to move into their new house
right and that got delayed because
they're literally
always gonna do that they get stuck in
there you know what i mean
revolution we teach everyone thinks rent
uh service competition's tourist tourist
tourists no it's business contractors
it's relocators it's um it's
professionals and it's tourists but when
you know your market you know so that's
awesome also you've made a lot of good
friends as well it's not just you just
smashing it you've made up some really
good friends yeah look when i got in one
of the reasons why i joined academy i'll
be honest with you i mentioned earlier
about how i could be a bit thick at
times you know i never wanted to go
alone in property i always i'm a people
person and i knew i wanted to work with
other people a because i enjoy working
with people and sharing the success and
the ups and the downs with somebody else
and it takes the responsibilities as
well having a responsibilities as well
but there's certain things i'm not
confident with you know certain things
like the back end stuff holly helly
helps me massively with with working my
way around a pc and whatnot and just
just there's general stuff i'm not that
confident with doing so i like to work
with people you know i've got my
strengths they've got theirs and when
you come together with someone else i
think it works you know and also the
deals i've got up north i'm working with
people who live in the area as well up
north i'm down south
um so yeah i never wanted to get a
property alone or always wanted to do it
with other people yeah i think as well
environments really important you
mentioned about when you're hearing from
negative people it can get into your
head a bit but when you're around
positive people it kind of lifts you up
yeah yeah and i think that part of the
academy it it's about being around
people that are winning i mean you run
the same launch pad as who were you on
the launch pad with chris chris chap and
patrick and emma cannon and thomas
atkinson
um callum mathison you know he was all
yeah that absolutely and they're all
financially free i'm the last one on the
winners on a wednesday right they're all
funny they're all financially free
they're all doing really well um what
would you say
to somebody that was kind of like
you know having that little voice we
talk about their little voice that's
like oh you can't do this or when you're
having an estate agent shut the door in
your face and say oh everyone's coming
and asking for this we don't do it it
can be really easy to tell yourself i
need to stop now now's the time to quit
now it's time to give up what would your
advice be
well you need you need a decent why i
think as well do you know what i mean
it's like you've mentioned before if
you're just getting in it to make the
money um
then you your quitter eat quit easier
you know holly and i we've got some
reasons
oh i'll get a bit emotional that's good
man that's cool what's what's your
reason for doing this
uh well a lot of it is because of the
gym
you know what i mean because of the gym
and i know i know like um it's good with
a gym obviously i know i need to find
another source of income tonight yeah so
uh we just want to have a good life we
just want to have a good life we want to
i don't know we've got nieces and
nephews that we can look after our
family that we want to look after you
know that that's kind of like my wife
i've got families
your nieces your nephews yeah i've got a
good reason to go out there and um and
and just go through the nose and things
you know what you ain't broke your nose
you ain't broke me rib yeah i can just
move on to the next one and for those
people that are just getting started
you've got to be able to just go for
that go for that no i read that book go
for no and you know you've got to be
able to just um
go for it you've got to stay positive
you've got to stay positive and it is a
numbers game it is 100 a numbers game
you used to fight a lot and you just
have to step into the ring or the cage
or whatever fight yeah yeah yeah and um
yeah right but you told me that he told
me that when you actually go into an
estate agency
you used to think you know what at least
i'm not going to leave here with broken
bones or a black eye broken nose and you
and you'd walk in for that yeah and for
me that was quite inspiring and and
motivating because
everybody even even myself yourself now
you sometimes you might think oh i don't
want to do that out of fear but actually
what's the worst that can happen do you
know it is fear as well and one of the
things why i used to get so nervous
fighting was because i used to i didn't
i didn't care about getting hurt pain
just does not bother me it's about
looking like a [ __ ] it's about
getting knocked out in front of everyone
and looking like a wally there's a lot
of people out there that are afraid of
making a fool of themselves and they're
afraid of
doing something and looking like an
idiot or whatever you know people that
are afraid of losing money obviously i
can understand that no one wants to lose
money you know what i mean like people
are scared to make the commitment
because they might lose money but if you
get if you get if you learn
if you if you get the training and
you're confident in what you're doing
you've got the right people around you
are you minimizing them risks you know i
mean but
yeah
what is it that kept you going through
that initial sort of three month
hardship of getting that first deal what
is it that kept you going
i just i've just got that personality
you know i mean i've just got that i'm
not going to give in because it was
quite i've been close so many times i've
been very close like there was there was
an opportunity in watford a brand new
block of um two apartments were built in
watford and i nearly i was so close to
securing them you know when you said
don't let your emotions take over and
things like that well i was emotionally
attached to this building and it didn't
happen because they wanted too much rent
and i had to walk away you know so i was
so close and i knew i knew yeah you know
it's like at the end of the tunnel i'm
going to get there yeah i knew i was
going to get there i could just i just
knew it but when you get that first deal
with csx to see it's amazing it's like
and then when you get your first one
it's so much easier to get more because
like i can go into agencies now
and i can i can sort of say you know
this is my company this is my instagram
page this is what i do and now for
example we've got all our
if we run a tight ship now you know
because we've had parties we've had
issues we've run such a tight ship now i
explained to them how we work and how we
do everything pay by link and we've got
the security cameras and we've got the
sound monitors and how we've got our
security team nearby and how we monitor
everything and how we ensure that we
don't get parties and and
now now i can explain that to agents
they're like this guy knows his stuff
so it becomes easier it's that first
deal getting it over the line
and you can't necessarily
figure out i always say that i don't try
and figure out the xyz until you've
walked the abc
you can't know everything about
everything until you've actually done it
we teach you all the basics we teach you
enough to go and do it but then the real
real real learning comes into play is
when you do have a party you think oh no
how am i gonna you you know the real
nitty-gritty you've also got a whole
bunch of other uh projects which we're
going to talk about in a future
interview but you've refinanced your
house yeah talk to me about that well i
was off the mindset
of
paying off your mortgage i've never i'm
one of these people i've never really
been in debt i don't like having money
and if in a few times in the past i've
owed money i've done whatever i can fast
to get myself out of debt and to me a
mortgage was just a debt and i wanted to
get it paid off and my dad was saying
son you want to be mortgage-free
mortgage-free you know as well so
i just don't ever think i could for
years over time like you know what every
time i go i got made redundant that went
straight off my mortgage so i just
wanted to be mortgage free and then when
i went to the course and i found out
about you know refinancing your house
what's the point in paying off your
mortgage if you're
if you're if you're sitting on a 400
house but you're still struggling to pay
the bills you know you'll be better off
i would have been better off 500 pound a
month yeah 500 a month whereas if i can
pull my money out and invest it wisely
into property you know the strategy that
i'm doing is i'm putting the money in
and then at the end of it when i
refinance i'll get majority of my money
out one of the deals i'm getting more
than my money out believe it or not and
then you can you keep using the same pot
of money to recycle your money so now
you've got your portfolio you've
refinanced your house you're using that
money to do the buy referential finance
strategy which is another thing that we
teach on the academy yeah and you're
putting it in pulling out putting input
out how many properties are you buying
at the moment i've got two
i've just completed last week on one
congrats which is um a derelict seven
bedroom property at the moment we're
making into a six bedroom all on suite
converting a basement into a splitting
of titles and converting into a two
bedroom flat another one in darlington
which is um at the moment is a derelict
four four flats and we're turning that
into a seven bedroom uh luxury hmo as
well focusing on like the higher end
market you know working professionals so
um yeah the darlington one's looking
good we're going to be leaving a little
bit of money in there not a lot maybe 10
grand each yeah but the the burnley one
we're looking putting our money out on
that and maybe even
we will see in the next video but uh i
don't know i don't want to jinx it but
we're looking at putting out a nice
chunk as well absolutely awesome so it's
going to be effectively a free house and
some yeah they'll be generating between
the two of them conservatively 1500 a
month for me that's brilliant you know
what i mean so excellent i'm really
excited about that my first sort of like
project some actually purchasing you
know names yeah how do you feel right
now looking back on all you've done over
the last couple of years we've been here
i don't know i'm excited i'm buzzing
it's a bit surreal to be honest with
y'all because uh
i don't know like say holly and i our
lifestyles aren't changed you know i
know we're doing well with the essays
our lifestyles have changed in a way
that we're focusing on on property a lot
more obviously but financially any the
money that i'm making within their
businesses is staying in their
businesses and we're building it and
we're growing it eventually we will
we're just going to keep reinvesting it
you know you're putting all the money
back into growing your portfolio i'm
happy doing what i'm doing at the moment
i enjoy teaching people thai boxing it's
a passion i enjoy it right you know so i
don't need don't want to give that up
just yet and um
yeah so
the fact that i'm here now you know it's
only the other day really i was having a
little telly up and thinking
blimey you know that's that's that's
doing all right yeah doing all right
once these hmos and that and the barn
yeah uh kick in you know that's that's
that's mad holly's holly's gonna be um
sort of at the moment holly's works
full-time in recruitment and she's gonna
be she's gonna be the plan is to leave
the recruitment and work on our
businesses uh full-time so that's gonna
free up more time for me as well you
know i spend seems to spend a lot of
time on
guest replies and emails and stuff like
that it can take me ten minutes to send
an email whereas honey will be like gone
yeah i mean i think the thing is as well
everybody's in property for a different
reason with a different goal your reason
wasn't i want to get out my job as soon
as i can you love what you do your
reason was
i can't do this forever and i want to be
in a position where financially i can
stop when i need to and i can continue
looking after my family i can continue
living the life that i want to live and
i think what you've done is absolutely
amazing i'm really impressed
it's great to have you as a student and
also to know you as a friend and i'm
looking forward to visiting some of your
your properties as well i'm going to be
coming out maybe i'll be staying as a
guest and some of the in some of these
events because it sounded fabulous
um what would you say how would you
summarize your experience through the
academy over the last couple of years
yes it's off it's been amazing like so
you've highlighted a lot of the facts
today you know i've made some great
friends and because because me being me
you know i always wanted to build
relationships with people that are
where i want to be you know so i've
always at school and college i copied
people you know i was always that kid
like what's your answer for number four
because i couldn't work out myself so
having a group of people around me that
i can i can bounce off and i can ask
questions and i can learn from you know
it's that's worth the fee in itself yeah
it really is and and obviously giving me
the confidence to refinance my house
i've worked for for all them years and
be able to go out there and invest in
the property you know yeah i've got no
regrets of yeah if i could rewind and
turn back the time i'd i'd do it again
yeah 100 awesome for me it's worked well
massive massive congrats and look
forward to seeing your winners wednesday
part two in about six months yeah i'm
sure guys i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did please do me a favor and
smash the like button also drop a
comment below what did you like best in
the interview if you want to see more
videos like this you can check out an
entire playlist up right here you can
subscribe to the channel over here and
if you want to join me at the property
investors crash course it's completely
free let's meet let's teach you to do
the same thing too and you can do that
below the link is in the description
thanks so much for watching i'll see you
next time peace out